hello everyone and welcome back to the
morphe saga we are continuing the 1858
match between paul morphy and paul
giorno uh in paris we've
left it off uh uh after the the the
previous two games that morphe won uh
first game was a rather clean second not
so much but this game
as the title suggests could be very well
uh
morphy's worst game ever now uh that
could mean a lot so let's first check
out the game
and see why this is so so morphe again
with the white pieces
opens with e4 that we have e5 by journal
knight to f3
knight to c6 uh sorry nice to see six
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 now
uh we have bishop to c5 and now morphe
of course
goes for the evans gambit we have b4 uh
you don't have to think twice if the
situation arises on the board where the
evans gambit can be played morphy will
play it
but here we don't have the usual bishop
captures on b4 we don't have the retreat
to b6 or the retreat to e7
but rather we have d5 and this is the
high encountering gambit to the evan's
gambit
we've seen it already on this channel
and it is uh well
if you don't know what you're doing it
can be a very tricky idea
so here uh e captures on d5 morphe grabs
the pawn and now attacks the knight here
knight captures on b4 uh and now
basically you're inviting white to
capture on e5 but
that's not all that great if knight
captures bishop d4
will put pressure on the knight and the
rook and okay
it's not that you actually lose a piece
because after for example c3
you will capture the knight and now you
still can't capture because the rook
would hang but you will play d4
and only now after the bishop moves will
you grab the knight but still
you have uh double the d pawns it's not
not something you want to look forward
to with white
so instead after this knight captures on
b4 we have c3
pushing back in the night much like you
would in the normal evans gambit and now
knight captures on the e5 and here we
have queen to b3 by morphy
and it is as of move 7 that this
position has never been
reached again and for good reasons it
doesn't uh
yield all that much for white if black
plays properly and black does play
properly here we have c6 cementing that
knight on d5
uh we have castles by morphe now with
ideas of knight captures on e5 which is
kind of
a dangerous uh uh while the king is
still here on e1
but now it's definitely a threat so here
e4 by journal
and rook to e1 pinning that pawn so
the knight cannot be captured we have f5
defending the pawn
and now uh sherna spent a lot of moves
um
uh to you know advance those pawns to
defend the e4 pawn but his king is still
in the center and he will need
at least two moves to get it back to
safety so morphe of course attacks the
center we have d3
attacking e4 and preparing to win
material and open up the e file so here
we have knight
g to uh to f6 now offering this pawn
uh but it's um uh not hovering defending
the pawn but now bishop to g5 morphe
pins one of the defenders and now is
threatening pawn captures here
and here jordan uh couldn't um
uh find the the correct continuation he
played queen to d6 he decided to unpin
uh so the knight would once again be
defending e4 but i will show
uh what uh fun lines happen after black
just castles now you offer the e4 pawn
and after the pawn is captured for
example captures captures and captures
uh
now black has this bishop captures an f2
move so
you will not be able to capture the e4
pawn because of this idea
and now of course you cannot capture if
you capture then you
uh eliminate the rook with check just
knife captures an e4 with
check you also pick up the bishop later
on and the black is just completely
winning
so here you would have to go to h1 and
then after king to h1
we would have this position where black
is uh
perfectly fine he has more than enough
compensation b5 can either
even force uh some further trades for
example captures captures and now
uh black is just uh completely dominant
so instead after bishop to g5 we have
queen to d6
uh arjuna doesn't spot this very nice
trick with castles and now he's once
again defending this pawn
but now morphy eliminates uh oh well he
could go knight b to d2 once
uh before capturing an f6 as it adds
another attacker to d4 pawn
but he decides to capture on f6 first we
have knight captures on f6 and now
knight b to d2 again adding a third
attacker here
and again it's um it's uh it's a very
interesting position um you could go
knight g4
like go after the f2 pawn then white
will play something like d4 maybe
bishop back to b6 and it's not great but
at least you've prevented white from
opening up the e file and you will not
be able to
not castle but you will be able to maybe
bring pieces into the game maybe you can
castle queen
side who knows but instead after this
knight beat to d2 we have b5 by journal
now attacking morphy's bishop and now
morphy goes for
bishop to f7 check again morphy misses
the
at the very nice continuation of d
captures on e4
now threatening just uh opening up the
the e file with captures on f5 and with
the bishop controlling this diagonal
it's going to be very deadly the rook
can come to d1
not a lot you can do here you could grab
the bishop but then again
uh you could just play queen captures on
c4 and again
not much uh can be done here for black
if you place if if you try and keep on
to the material
you have to keep defending this bishop
also e5 is coming so that's going to be
dangerous you could play something
like this but the just e captures an f5
with
check and now you cannot go here you
have to go to the d file and after king
d8 you're gonna go knight b3
with a double attack on the bishop rook
a to d1 check is coming
the rooks are completely dominant here
uh it's a game over for black
so instead instead of going for this
after b5 morphe goes for bishop to f7
check
uh but this gives black counter play
black plays king to f8
and now we have d captures on e4 again
d4
might be a bit bit of a safer option
here but morphe goes for d captures on
e4
and here was uh black's last uh moment
where he could have gone for
a better move queen to e7 for black just
makes sense
uh as uh you go after the bishop on f7
and also you add another defender to the
e4 pawn and you prepare f captures on e4
so queen to e7
uh is everything uh black needs here
however uh black accepted on e4 he
played
f captures on e4 and now the game is
once again
winning for morphe so morphe goes for it
knight captures on e4 we have ninth
characters and
rook captures on e4 now preparing to
bring the other rook over to d1
bishop to f5 attacking morphy's rook on
a4 and now
rook to d1 again going after the black
queen we have queen to f6
and now morphy goes for knight to e5 and
this is all again
uh from a completely winning position
morphe again plays for tricks and again
uh finds himself in not the the greatest
of positions because here okay if black
is uh
greedy goes for material play something
like bishop captures on e4 then yes
knight d7 check wins the game on the
spot
but if he doesn't uh let's say he plays
something like g6
then white doesn't really have a good
way to continue the attack
uh you have to move the rook and after
that the black king will go to g7 the
rook will come
into the game obviously not there for
example the d8
and everything will be fine black has a
very nice control of the dark squares
and you will be able to
wiggle around the light squares but
instead again after this knight to e5
morphe's opponent played bishop captures
on f2 with
check and now again what do you play
here uh obviously you could capture the
bishop but if you capture the bishop
then uh you get this discovery you just
move the bishop
uh hopefully by by grabbing the rook and
after the king moves you
you're also going to capture the knight
and now black is just up too much
material and
winning morphy not one to be tricked so
easily goes king to h1
first and now again it's black to move
what do you play here
uh here we have rook to d8 bringing that
rook into the game
and trying to trade off uh morphy
sparrow rooks
uh and morphy again uh misses the
the uh pretty much instant win here
murphy plays and knights the d7 check
which is kind of also playing for tricks
the the brute forcing rook captures on
d8
uh is is winning on the spot for example
captures captures and now knight
captures on c6 is enough uh the queen is
under attack
uh you also might have some ideas of
maybe rook to rook to e8 in some lines
you don't have to worry about to check
maybe the queen is guarding d1
so here we would probably see something
like queen to c8 and then
bishop to h5 we threaten checkmate here
and there's not a lot you can do here to
defend you can play g6 the block
checkmate but then rook the e7
again we're threatening checkmate here
and now there's pretty much
only only one thing you can play bishop
to e6 to kind of prolong the game but
still after rook captures you defend the
the knight here and you are just winning
uh the uh well of course the bishop
cannot be captured as then is just
made into king j7 or you know just going
to f7 checkmate so this is not possible
so rook captures uh the uh the obvious
moves move
wins but morphy still goes for knight to
d7 check
again he decides to complicate things
and what do you play here of course
now the rook cannot move from the back
rank otherwise you get rook to e8 to
checkmate
so you have to play something else uh
sorry about that
uh so after this check uh morphe's
opponent played rook captures on d7
sorry he played bishop captures on d7
and now morphy goes for
rook captures on d7 uh luckily there is
no queen to h1 otherwise you'd have to
worry about that as well the c3 pawn
guards
against that uh very nicely so here of
course again you cannot capture rook the
e8 will be checkmate so here
rook the c8 by journal and now morphy
plays bishop to h5 again queen to be for
check is just deadly here but okay
bishop to h5 threatening
rook to f7 uh which would come with
check then you just win the queen and
the game
so g6 and now comes rook e to e7 this is
what morphe
goes for instead and by doing this he
allows black to give up uh
the queen for two rooks which of course
black does with queen captures on e7
rook captures and king captures on e7
and now there is only one winning move
for morphe
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this
move while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
uh going uh for for the temple move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's bishop to g4 bishop to g4
attacking that rook and see it
because you cannot allow black to make a
consolidating move
if you play something like bishop to f3
uh
it uh you allow for example rook h to e8
and now with both rooks into the game
it's not going to be easy for example
queen
goes here with checking to f7 and now uh
already you have problems
there's the thread of rook t1 which
would end in checkmate and
even though you have a queen two rooks
are extremely powerful so here
congratulations to everyone who found
bishop to g4 because now black needs to
react to this you have to move the rook
uh we have rook c to d8 and now
comes queen to b4 again a mistake by
morphe here
uh it's uh i have no idea how do you
miss something
how do you not play queen to e6 here
this is uh
uh i i think morphe maybe was just
looking at other games or something or
maybe he already
uh defeated him two to zero and then he
just uh you know played silly moves but
uh there's really not a lot to consider
here queen e6
check there's only one move for the
black king king to f8 and then queen f6
will reach the position from the
thumbnail
wherever the king moves uh you're either
gonna grab one of the rooks or even if
uh
king goes here then you can even play
bishop to e6 checkmate so this is um
this is pretty crazy so if morphe did
not go for this morphe instead went for
queen to b4 with check
and now we have c5 and c5 is again a
mistake by journal
uh if he had played rook the d6 with the
with the idea of bringing the other rook
here then you've activated all of your
pieces and that there are no tricks
there's no
uh no uh the trickery white can use to
to to even think about winning some
material
but instead of this i should not play
the c5 and now
yes morphe can do a lot more if you
played queen to e4 with
check and now you have to be very
careful the bishop on f2 is very exposed
and
you don't really have a good square for
the king king the d6 was played
but now just queen to f4 with check
connecting with the bishop with king to
c6 and now
queen captures on f2 so grabbing that
bishop
uh the light square bishop guards the d1
square so you don't have to worry about
rook to d1
uh we have rook h2 f8 trying to get the
queen away from this
square but now bishop to f3 check this
is super important
uh because uh even if something uh
well you can't even sacrifice here
because then just the queen captures and
this square is again covered so this is
not possible everybody white clothes who
just capture with the g pawn doesn't
really matter
uh point is there's not much for black
to do here king the b6 was played
but here uh morphe just played h3 he
made some breeding room for the king and
after rook to d1 chicken king h2
it was in this position that poster not
resigned to the game
on move 33 as there is nothing more to
be done here
so really really crazy stuff i don't
think we've seen
uh when i say morphe's worst game and
it's funny because of course he still
won the game
but uh the the the there have been other
games that morphe lost
but they've just they just weren't this
bad
uh his opponent played uh some sort of a
brilliancy or you know
they played at least like five moves uh
that were the top moves recommended by
the engine but here
morphe it's like he was trying to to
either lose or at least give your no one
draw
but in the end even that was not enough
but yeah pretty crazy game maybe they
were drunk maybe they had like
you know two bottles of wine each i
don't know
but uh this is uh
i think uh so far of all the games that
we've shown uh the most
imprecise uh morphe game uh so far
uh so those are the three games uh
morphe played against paul giorno
uh in uh cafe de la uh
uh i don't know how to pronounce it
sorry about that uh but
uh yeah uh morphe is now waiting for uh
for uh harvest and harvest will be back
on saturday and then morphe will
challenge him
but uh uh we'll see if he will uh if
harwich will accept the challenge or
will he try to pull a staunton
uh but we still don't know what was
going to happen with staunton
uh but yeah uh harvest is a very strong
opponent he played against some very
strong players who won some very nice
matches
uh he stood his own against um against
adolf anderson
so it's gonna be a pretty pretty awesome
match so stay tuned
for that uh so uh this is uh i believe
morphy's
worst game so hope i hope you guys
enjoyed that but it it still was a very
very interesting game to see
uh i would like to thank luis medrano
from heart
um
[Music]
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day